hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
angel deluse's essay bartleby
or the formula one of the most
interesting and
indeed i'd even go so far as to say
fascinating aspects
of the essay has to do with this
contrast that he's making
between characters and originals which
also connects with this
distinction he's invoking between
secondary nature
and primary nature and the implications
for this go far beyond just melville's
work
in fact he brings up dostoevsky and
other people as well and he says that
this is
this is an aspect of an ancient
theory which we're going to get to
shortly
before we do that i want to jump uh
into a remark he makes a little bit
later before he's going to transition to
another section
where he says what is the biggest
problem haunting melville's
his body of work and he says to recover
the already sensed identity
no doubt it lies in reconciling the two
originals
right and what what are the two
originals he's talking about there
he's mentioning billy budd this this
late work that has to be in some respect
reconstructed
and that's a work in which he says
melville
brings in two originals there is a
demonic maniac being which is clagger
the master at
arms and then there's an angelic
hypochondriac being
this is under the melvillian site is you
know
psychiatry aspect that we've talked
about elsewhere
and that would be billy budd himself
so that's a a story in which we don't
just have one original we have two of
them
and you could say well how do you
harmonize the two of them deleuze says
that's not really what melville
is fundamentally about he says thereby
also in reconciling the original
the kind of character that that
represents the original
with secondary humanity the inhuman
with the human now isn't that
interesting both of these are
humanity in a certain sense but the
inhuman human
and then the human human and these are
going to correspond to
secondary nature and primary nature so
we need to jump back
in the work to where he first invokes
this
and it's in the passage where he's
describing
um monomaniacs like ahab
and then he brings up klagert and he
talks about this as
metaphysical perversion and he says this
is what the narrator suggests when he
recalls an ancient
and mysterious theory an expose of which
is found in
sod so we should pause here for a second
deluse is not saying that assad is the
first person to come up with this he's
saying that assad just
manages to clarify this by the way the
reference
in this is to uh you know literature
on saad as well and you can find that if
you if you get the book and look at the
note
that he's talking about some 20th
century interpretations of assad
but it's also there in dasad and can be
pulled out of his works and it's also
there in melville and it's also there
in previous authors so what is this
ancient theory he tells us
secondary sensible nature so the the
phenomenal world that we see
and it's going to include more than just
the phenomenal world
as we will soon see but let's just stick
with that phenomenal nature
as we encounter it as we experience it
that he says is governed by the law
capital l or laws while
innately depraved beings participate in
a terrible
super sensible primary nature original
and oceanic which knowing no law
pursues its own irrational aim through
them
nothingness nothingness and
i want to pause here for a second to
bring up something that deleuze is not
going to invoke until later
transcendentalism this this american
movement in philosophy and literature
and even
in politics and some other things as
well
is connected with this the notion that
there
is understanding
and then there's reason and that reason
would be deeper
it would connect with something that
exceeds just the understanding the
world of laws that's coming to these
transcendentalists through
coleridge who is reading german
idealistic
philosophy and de luz rightly calls
attention to the
interconnections and overlaps between
transcendentalist philosophy pragmatism
and melville so there's there's some
really interesting and rich connections
to explore there so he goes on and he
says we can classify melville's great
characters at one pole there's these
monomonetics or demons
driven by the will to nothingness at the
other polar angels
or saintly hypochondriacs we've already
talked about this
in in other places and he says that both
poles
both types of characters ahab and
bartleby
belong to this primary nature and they
inhabit it
they can they constitute it everything
sets them in
opposition and yet they're perhaps the
same creature
primary original stubborn
seized from both sides marked merely
with a plus
or minus sign right so
they could be and which which gets the
plus in which gets the minus it depends
on whether we're talking about agency or
goodness right
or innocence if we're talking about
agency it's the demonic
as opposed to the angelic which he talks
about is being petrified frozen
unable to act and only being acted upon
being passive if we're talking about
goodness and evil then perhaps the
the monomaniac is the evil and the
angelic is the good
and a good and evil beyond the good and
evil of secondary nature
and here's where we should talk about
several other
things that come in he says there exists
a third type of character in melville
the one on the side of the law
the guardian of the divine and human
laws of secondary nature
the prophet so this is very important
divine and
human laws of secondary nature he's
going to call it the representative
of the law before too long and he also
points out there's a little bit earlier
in the essay
that melville thinks that psychologists
can't really understand this distinction
between primary and secondary nature
as much as a person can understand it
and they can't apprehend what's going on
in primary nature there's stuck within
the world
that they know and so this points out to
us that this is not merely a phenomenal
world
of laws this is also a world of
sociality customs humanity
is understanding itself through
psychological laws or irregularities as
opposed to merely physical laws and you
know this is very conscient in a certain
respect isn't it
conscious in the way that's going to
lead to shoping
rather than to to hegel and these
prophets are representatives of
the laws and at the end at the same time
as
the lose points out there's an ambiguity
here they are able to see into the
primary nature that so fascinates them
they're nonetheless represented as a
secondary nature and its laws
they cannot ward off the demons the
latter are too quick for the law
nor can they save the innocent the
irresponsible they immolate them
in the name of the law and and this is
the part of the essay that when i
first read this oh 25
years ago so fascinated me these these
prophets who can actually see to some
extent what's going on here
and are unable to make the law really
work to do what it ought to do
for human beings which would include the
innocence
to hold back the monominaex
and so he goes on and he says that torn
between
these two natures with all those
contradictions these characters are
extremely important
but these prophets do not have the
status of the two others they're
witnesses narrators interpreters
and he goes on and he says
this is where we get to the the
originals versus
characters and he's going to tell us
after invoking the underground man as
well as kafka and mussel
that with these two types of
characters uh the monominax and the
hypochondriacs we go beyond characters
he says
melville introduces an essential
distinction between the characters in a
novel so they're all characters right
and he says we must above all avoid
confusing true
originals with characters that are
simply
remarkable or singular particular
this is because the particulars who tend
to be quite populous in a novel have
characteristics that determine their
form properties that make up their image
they are influenced by their milieu and
by each other
so that their actions and reactions are
governed by
general laws though in each case they
retain a particular
value the sentences they utter are their
own but governed by the general laws of
language
so they may be very
interesting but they they fit into
a kind of logic that applies to
secondary nature by the way
deleuze uses this term logic to include
both
secondary and primary nature logic has
to be broader than just formal
propositional logic
it has to genuinely become uh an
engagement with with
thought as possible thought is engaged
with with reality
so what are these originals then
he goes on and he tells us that
[Music]
here we go we do not even know if an
original exists
in an absolute sense apart from the
primordial god
and it's already something extraordinary
when we encounter one
melville admits it's difficult to
imagine how a novel might include
several of them why why because each one
he says
is a powerful solitary figure that
exceeds any explicable form
it projects flamboyant traits of
expression that mark the stubbornness
of a thought without image a question
without response
and extreme and non-rational logic
figures of life and knowledge they know
something inexpressible lives something
unfathomable
they have nothing general about them and
are not particular they escape
knowledge defy psychology now even
though they do
break forth into this secondary world
where they do have a
they are entering into a psychology a
language a logic a laws all these
sorts of things they nonetheless
they they escape it in part because
they're coming from something
that was greater than it and that this
uh you know world that we're used to is
only
you might say the light side to invoke
the old show the dark tales from the
dark side
if you don't know that reference google
it and it's there's a really great intro
which begins by talking about the world
that we live in the sunlit world
that we take for reality and then
the narrator and his very creepy voice
says but there is
unknown to many of us a dark side
and that dark side is not just the
polarity
the negative image as the video would
seem to suggest
the dark side would be the primary
nature
more real but less easy
to discuss so he says originals are
beings of primary nature but they're
inseparable from the world or from
secondary nature where they exert
their effect they reveal its emptiness
the imperfection of its laws the
mediocrity
of particular creatures the world as
masquerade prophets
are the ones who can recognize the wake
dulu says that originals leave in the
world and the unspeakable confusion and
trouble they can cause in it
so the original and primary nature
cannot be
systematized cannot be brought within
the realm of scientific knowledge or
even you know
metaphysics or philosophical knowledge
or we might say morality and ethics
it can penetrate it to a certain degree
we can understand to a certain degree
but there's always something seemingly
arbitrary about whatever is coming out
of primary nature including
these originals he's the original says
melville is not subject to the influence
of his milieu
on the contrary he throws a vivid a
livid
white light on his surroundings much
like the light that accompanies the
beginning of things in genesis
originals are sometimes the immobile
source of this light
and sometimes it's dazzling passage and
so
you know who are these originals well
we've already mentioned some of them
we have ahab we have cloggart and billy
budd
who are the prophets well the attorney
captain vera right
and then who are the angelic figures
billy budd is one
bartleby is another and
all of these are ways in which
primary nature is breaking forth
now something that we should close on
and thinking about
primary nature assuming this is actually
true
would then be something that would
you know be beyond us
how is it that it's revealed in
literature
isn't literature merely an assemblage of
codes of arrangements
maybe there's something about literature
that allows it to penetrate
into our minds into us into our world
of largely secondary nature and to
act like a meta prophet in a certain way
maybe that's what melville is maybe
that's what to lose
is and on that suggestion i will just
close off here
and let you mull that over
you